bonsoir et merci de prendre le temps de
répondre à nos questions sur arte france
le conseil scientifique appelle à se
préparer à une deuxième vague de
couronnes 1 virus à l'automne parmi les
précautions à prendre pour s'en prémunir
les gestes barrière le port du masque la
distanciation les arrêtés préfectoraux
on l'a beaucoup dit se multiplient pour
imposer le port du masque en extérieur
est ce que le gouvernement n'a pas aussi
un rôle à jouer
oui alors évidemment mais en préambule
je vais simplement apporter mon soutien
et l'ensemble des parlementaires aux
libanais vu le drame qui se passe à
beyrouth et je vous répond évidemment le
gouvernement a pris toute la mesure de
ce set cette pandémie depuis depuis le
début et on observe effectivement un
certain relâchement et on en appelle à
la responsabilité de chacun et notamment
on rappelle les gestes de préconisations
et puis jean castex le premier ministre
vendredi s'est rendu à l'aéroport de
roissy charles de gaulle aussi pour
également annoncé que 16 pays sur la
liste rouge avait été signalé et que les
ressortissants français ou les
binationaux qui arriverait sur le
territoire devront avoir fait un test au
préalable de 70 heures avant où elles
seront invités à faire un test sur sur
l'aéroport même avec un commande des
vagins résultats 48 heures après un
appel à la 14ème si besoin était maire
justement est ce que cette mesure ne
vise pas à un peu tard est-ce qu'elle
n'est pas des raisons non plus qu'il ne
faudrait pas un remplacement
systématique en 14 elle pour ces
voyageurs qui reviennent de 16 pays
classés à risque d'imposer d'imposer
systématiquement je pense que cc c'est
une illusion
il faut bien savoir que ces voyageurs
d'abord se fait uniquement des français
il ya eu je crois 540 est à peu près
samedi il y a un ce qu'on parlait
justement du contrôle tracing ils
donnent leur numéro téléphone leurs
mails et de toute façon il faut bien
savoir aussi que il y a également des
faux positifs
faux négatifs dans le cadre des tests il
suffit aussi que le patient soit au
contact du virus deux sont très très
précoce pour que le test ne soit pas
encore positive et donc je pense que
justement on peut pas il n'y a pas de
risque zéro si vous vouliez à ce moment
là il faudrait faire aussi des tests
pour les gens qui arrivent de barcelone
en voiture pour qu'ils arrivent en train
ou en bateau et pourquoi pas et pourquoi
pas alors pour cour pourquoi pas de
toute façon vous savez les réponses du
gouvernement sont très réactives et on a
tout des signaux à notamment
épidémiologique et qui permettent
justement de suivre au plus près
l'évolution de la propagation du virus
donc pourquoi pas je laisse le soin aux
ministres donc au premier ministre et au
midi de la santé d'en décider mais
jusqu'à maintenant les décisions qui ont
été prises ont été tout à fait réactive
avère en lien avec le conseil de
supérieure scientifique
alors ces tests de dépistage était
présentée comme la solution pour limiter
la propagation du virus
on est pourtant loin des 700 mille tests
par semaine qui était promis par le
gouvernement c'est le parcours du
combattant visiblement pour se faire
dépister
comment est-ce que vous l'expliquez
comment est-ce qu'on peut y remédier
selon vous mais tout simplement parce
qu'au départ au départ vous et qu' il
fallait avoir une ordonnance hu allait
prendre un rendez vous auprès du médecin
puis aller au laboratoire et lors une
mesure a été prise je crois c'était la
semaine la semaine dernière de telle
sorte que chacun peut aller se faire
tester sans avoir une ordonnance donc il
ya une réactivité
après c'est bien sûr on soutient les
laboratoires at war peuvent peuvent
favre peuvent faire le test donc rouler
on s'adapte en fonction de dudu taux de
propagation des virus du virus pardon il
aussi difficile
visiblement s'appuyer sur l'application
de traçage stop convient d'aller très
peu télécharger récemment elle a été
jugée d'un intérêt sanitaire concret
bien négligeable selon un rapport
sénatorial stop qu'ovide vient aussi de
se voir infliger un camouflet par
bruxelles on se retrouve en
techniquement exclus du projet
d'interface des applications antique
vide décentralisée de 18 autres pays
européens
est ce que c'est un flop est ce que ce
n'est pas un flop malheureux pour une
application qui effectivement on
pourrait servir à tracer d'avantagé à
remonter le fil des des rapprochements
entre malades ducobu 19 noms alors je
pense que tout est améliorable en tout
cas l intérêt d d'exister je pense que
c'est une c'est une première et et
peut-être servira-t-elle pour
malheureusement d'autres épidémies mais
il faut quand même rappeler c'est une
question de bon sens que la
responsabilité de chacun est engagé dans
la préconisation des des
gestes-barrières il suffit de se laver
les mains
je pense pas que sincèrement porter un
masque soit non plus une contrainte
exceptionnel si vous voulez donc moi moi
de toute façon si on veut arrêter cette
propagation du virus là vous avez un air
le taux de reproduction qui est en
moyenne de 1 38 en france et on sait que
le on est donc dans le seuil de
vigilance entre 1 et 1,5 et au delà de
1,5 on est au seuil d alerte et on sait
que un taux de 1,4 vous avez un temps de
doublement des cas en deux semaines mais
tous tout repose sur le la
responsabilité individuelle
c'est donc les mesures de préconisations
que je rappelle pas et que tous les
français connaissent c'est ça
l'essentiel
merci beaucoup d'avoir pris le temps de
répondre à nos questions marque de
lattes je rappelle que vous êtes député
est la république en marge de la n va
est médecin généraliste